hey everyone we're going to talk about
the aid actual causes of edema okay
edema is swelling and the lower
extremities and your ankles and your
feet and you see people all the time
with this and I'm just want to kind of
dig into what's behind it there's some
things that are more common but I wanted
to give you all the potential causes one
actually it's not as common but if
you're very low in protein let's say for
example you're even on keto and you
don't consume enough protein you could
start to have a problem where your your
ankle starts swelling up yeah so low
protein in the blood when the protein
the blood is called albumin if that's
low then the water accumulates in around
the cells so you just need to add more
approaching to the diet or improve the
digestion by adding more betaine how to
chloride or outside a vinegar to digest
the protein all right number two low
vitamin b1 and b1 deficiency is called
beriberi and a lot of people haven't b1
deficiency because they're consuming too
many carbs or alcohol or tea or
chocolate or various things I did a
whole video on that but if you're low
and b1 okay even sub clinically and
sometimes it doesn't really show up in a
blood test because it's not quite a
major thing but it's just low then you
can get swelling in the ankles okay in
the feet so it's real simple
take nutritional yeast and or b1 boom
problem solved all right three low
potassium if you're not consuming enough
greens then where's your potassium
coming from you need 4700 milligrams
every single day so you have to figure
out how you're gonna get that there is
some potassium and meat-like like for
example a chicken breast has like 300
milligrams but again you need 4700 so I
like to get it from vegetables
especially if you're doing like junk
food fast food you're gonna get a lot of
sodium and very little potassium now if
your salt sensitive or your you have too
much sodium instead of actually reducing
sodium increase potassium so if you were
to consume very high potassium foods
like believe it or not beet tops have
the highest amount of potassium
pistachios have a lot of potassium
avocados have a lot of potassium
Kayle has a lot of potassium so we we
beef that up no pun intended and then
what happens is your your swelling comes
down because when you increase potassium
you decrease sodium okay and sodium
retains water so that will help and by
the way usually down here diabetes is
another cause if you have diabetes
you're gonna usually be low on potassium
and b1 and that could be why you're
retaining fluid so you have want to
address this with health and keto in a
minute fasting but if you're a diabetic
or have insulin resistance or you're
pre-diabetic you're gonna hold fluid
just the nature of glucose you have too
much glucose in the body you're gonna
basically have like a fluid filled
sponge and you're gonna hold fluid the
heart if the heart is dysfunctional if
you have heart disease you you're
usually gonna have swelling on the left
ankle or foot okay so what causes this
many things but diabetes or high insulin
or sugar will do it okay eating junk
foods so you would want to do something
to improve the heart I have a lot of
videos on that your liver if your liver
is dysfunctional you have either a fatty
liver or cirrhosis chances are you're
gonna have swelling more on the right
ankle and foot okay but that can also
cause a problem too so there's I have
videos on what to do if you have a liver
problem I would say the best way to know
if you have a liver problem is just look
down right now and if you have a gut
okay if you can see your gut you have a
liver problem because that's the fatty
liver so you can get an ultrasound it'll
pick it right up but in order for you to
start getting that visceral fat the
liver usually is filled with fat and
then it spills over into around the
organs and the visceral so you can't see
it unless you do an ultrasound and
there's very few symptoms and unless you
it gets to the later stages kidney you
have two kidneys for their problem
you're gonna have swelling them both
both sides a lot of people have kidney
problems if they're a diabetic okay
so again that could be the reason why
your you have swollen ankles and feet
okay I mean the real answer to all of
these is to get your eating correct
there's so many people focusing on the
symptom like edema but they're not
getting the food corrected and that's
what I recommend of course you've heard
this a million times
healthy keto and in a minute fasting you
knew you knew I was gonna say that right
okay mix edema what is that
it looks like swelling but it's
puffiness it's not actually fluid it's a
waste product it's a little bit
different but you'll see these people
with like really big ankles and this is
a a thyroid problem a slow thyroid and
because Authority is so slow it retains
this certain despite product I'm not
going to give you the technical name and
that can make it make you look like you
have edema okay so you'd want to address
hypothyroid issues do a search on that I
have a lot of videos on that okay and
then we have blood sugar issues
diabetics pre-diabetics people with
insulin resistance you're going to have
fluid because the nature of the
retention of sodium and then comes the
water now if you actually have and these
conditions and you drink a lot of water
what happens is you're gonna retain more
fluid unless you get rid of the sodium
and or increase the potassium so taking
more potassium or electrolyte that has a
lot of potassium will push this fluid
out but you want to get to the root
cause so I put a link down below for
what I believe to be the best
electrolyte but if you have a demon you
must fix your diet alright thanks for
watching hey if you're liking this
content please subscribe now and I will
actually keep you updated on future
videos